ce soir les péchés de snc lavalin
il s'agit du plus grand projet
d'encadrement la plus grande fraude de
corruption de ce week-end et les remous
politiques autour de son absolution ou
pas notre gouvernement a fait son
travail en respectant toutes les normes
établies
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
c'était il ya sept ans justement forgé
de sa robe drapée d'un couple l'ex pdg
de snc lavalin niait toute connaissance
d'une affaire de corruption impliquant
son entreprise puis enquête a multiplié
les révélations sur des paiements de
pots de vin en libye c'est devenu
difficile de distinguer ce qui était
payée par sati et ce qui était payée par
snc lavalin en tunisie vous désirez que
snc lavalin soient sanctionnés
absolument
en algérie des plumes aval est arrivé en
algérie
déjà lors du premier contrat il a eu des
propos est chez nous est quelque chose
qui marche pour nous si ce test je sais
bien qu'aujourd'hui le car on regarde le
film parle d'un fait ou dit voyons y
aurait dit on à moi si je trouverais
d'allumer de la faute dans le cadre du
contrat du cuse hume des coudes veille
en marge d'un contrat pour le pont
jacques cartier
vous avez ouvert un compte avant tempus
vous aurez vous avez reçu plusieurs
paiements de la société
en 2015 c'est le choc et là stupeur chez
snc-lavalin l'entreprise elle même est
accusée au criminel de corruption quatre
ans plus tard ces accusations provoquent
une crise politique à ottawa
cette émission est incompatible avec les
conversations que j'ai eu avec jody il
ya quelques semaines l'ex ministre de la
justice john wall a quitté le conseil
des ministres de justin trudeau et
gerald butts le conseiller du premier
ministre à démissionner une semaine plus
tard après des semaines de silence
l'ex ministre jean louis borg a en fait
témoigner devant le comité de la justice
de la chambre des communes
mais ce qu'elle a dit ne marquera
certainement pas la fin de cette saga
nos collègues luc tremblay et anne
panassac ont couvert le doubs si snc
lavalin et ont fait plusieurs
révélations ici à notre émission ce soir
nous revenons sur nos reportages des
dernières années pour mieux comprendre
ce
on reproche exactement snc-lavalin and
rappelez-nous qu'il était le point de
départ de toutes ces enquêtes sur
snc-lavalin mais le printemps arabe
ça fait déjà plus de 7 ans parce qu'on
s'est aperçu à ce moment là qu'ils
avaient des hauts dirigeants de snc
lavalin qui aidait des membres de la
famille du dictateur en tunisie ou du
dictateur en libye à s'installer ici au
canada
que ce soit à montréal ou à toronto et
l'udc c'est en suisse que vous avez
trouvé pas mal d'informations
oui quelques mois plus tard avec notre
collègue la télévision au suisse yves
steiner on a obtenu le scoop de
l'arrestation de riadh ben aïssa le
vice-président de la compagnie
snc-lavalin il s était rendu en suisse
parce qu'il avait caché de l'argent la
boda des comptes dans des banques
suisses et surtout ce que ça nous a
révélé cette nouvelle là ça a été un
point tournant parce que pour la
première fois on comprenait que les
actes des hauts dirigeants dnc lavalin
était suffisamment grave qui pouvait
entraîner soit des accusations soient
des condamnations criminelles et sept
arrestations de riadh ben aïssa te
souviens c'est un scoop internationale
en a même été repris par le new york
times et c'est là qu'on a décidé d'aller
en libye 2013 pour aller voir sur le
terrain qu'est ce qu'on était des
contrats de snc-lavalin là bas alors
remontant en 2013 pour voir un extrait
de votre toute première enquête sur snc
lavalin
snc lavalin ce fleuron de l'ingénierie
canadienne a laissé sa marque partout
dans le monde jusqu'au pied des
montagnes en libye où elle était en
train de construire une prison
un projet qui démontre à quel point snc
lavalin était proche de la dictature de
kadhafi
la prison était construite un
partenariat avec une brigade de l'armée
libyenne dirigée par saadi kadhafi le
troisième fils de l'ex dictateur
plus qu'une simple association c'était
une filiale de snc lavalin dont le logo
est un mélange du bleu de la firme et du
vert du régime de kadhafi depuis la
révolution
le chantier est arrêté et des milices se
montent la garde pour éviter le pillage
leur chef n'a aucun doute que cette
prison aurait servi à torturer comme les
autres prisons de kadhafi ce partenariat
avec l'armée de kadhafi et l'idée de
ryad de benaïssa alors vice président de
snc lavalin
c'est lui qui signe cette lettre assadi
kadhafi proposant l'entente
il est l'architecte de ce système qui va
permettre à snc-lavalin d'obtenir de
lucratifs contrats en afrique du nord en
utilisant des fonds secrets
l' aventure libyenne de snc lavalin
débute dans les années 90 est intimement
liée à riadh ben aïssa
il est décrit comme un sauveur dans le
livre anniversaire des centaines
d'entreprises
l'histoire commence avec la construction
d'une rivière artificielle dans le
désert de libye
il s'agit d'acheminer l'eau des nappes
souterraines du désert jusqu'à la côte
une distance de plus de 3000 km un
projet ambitieux ou snc père alors
beaucoup d'argent raconte jacques
lamarre président de la firme à cette
époque c'est vrai ce week end on a eu
des problèmes et croyant et croyant vous
ne terminez projet derniers progrès mais
on a perdu une fortune fortune forte
riadh ben aïssa propose alors
d'embaucher un intermédiaire locales
pour réclamer les sommes que snc lavalin
engloutis dans le projet sans être payé
une compagnie qui s'appelle duvel
sécurité ici mais du vél récap toutefois
la moitié de la somme récupérée en guise
de paiement
on a discuté ouvertement c'est à ce
moment là vous n'acceptez fait celui-là
me souviens du principe aussi du
principe du 50% que je trouvais en outre
à jouer
à la même époque brad de scrabble dirige
snc lavalin internationale il se
souvient qu'on lui avait interdit de
voir les contrats libyens mais découvre
que bizarrement dans d'autres dossiers
riadh ben aïssa touche 2 % de commission
sur tous les contrats remportés par
snc-lavalin
c'est pour cette raison que j'ai
contacté un de mes amis de contentieux
il est revenu quelques jeux plus tard
elle me dit écoute on me dit dans de ne
pas toucher c'est ça
cela va dans le bade masses de neige ça
ne l'a pas contredit
oui ne pas par contre lui alors d'où
vient sa branche de la direction à ce
moment là il avait l'appui du président
encore plus étrange la compagnie du vel
qui est engagée par riadh ben aïssa pour
sortir snc lavalin du bourbier en libye
est enregistrée ici sur les plages des
îles vierges britanniques sont
administrateurs n'est pas un spécialiste
la construction en libye mais un avocat
à genève
rolland caufman lorsqu'un snc lavalin
engage un agent commercial ou une
compagnie est ce que la compagnie sait
qui sont les actionnaires de cette
compagnie ils doivent savoir
en théorie on embauche jamais quelqu'un
sans savoir exactement ce qu'il fait
quelles sont ses intérêts quelles sont
ses défauts
la personne qui se cache derrière la
compagnie duvel et qu'apporte le contrat
signé à genève est nul autre que riadh
ben aïssa lui même
[Musique]
à partir de ce moment les affaires vont
grand train pour snc en libye riadh ben
aïssa décrochent des contrats de plus en
plus important celui de sarir est aussi
celui de l'aéroport de bengazi
dans chaque cas la compagnie du vel est
impliqué c'est sympa c'est obligatoire
si vous nous la reprise réussie sadc à
diana da et doit se placer les affaires
vont si bien qu'en 2004 paul martin
alors premier ministre du canada se
déplace pour serrer la main à kadhafi
derrière cette façade brillante benaïssa
est en train de signer un pacte avec le
diable
un pacte avec le fils cadet fille qui va
durer des années et permettre de
détourner des millions de dollars en
libye
nous avons rencontré un proche de
kadhafi qui nous raconte comment les
affaires se concluait pour sa sécurité
nous avons masquer son visage j'étais
très proche d'un des fils du président
quel fils saadi kadhafi c'est lui qui
tirait les ficelles pour snc lavalin en
libye il nous explique comment le fameux
intermédiaire de snc lavalin la
compagnie du vel donne des pots-de-vin
au fils du président riadh ben aïssa
n'avez qu'à donner un coup de fil pour
obtenir un contrat en libye
et ça c'est la définition même de la
corruption bien sûr il y avait un
processus d'appel d'offres mais riadh
ben aïssa savaient qu'ils pouvaient
court circuiter tout ça il avait
seulement besoin d'appeler syndicats
défi pour s'entendre avec lui pour avoir
le contrat en échange
saadi kadhafi obtenait d'énormes
bénéfices personnels
[Musique]
c'est la compagnie du vel qui sert en
fait d'écran pour camoufler des pots de
vin par exemple le contrat signé avec
snc lavalin pour recouvrer les sommes
englouties dans le projet de la grande
rivière artificielle rapporte 32
millions dans les comptes suisses de
duels à partir de là benaïssa et kaufman
donne instruction banquiers suisses de
répartir l'argent à travers un méandre
de sociétés offshore
il est prévu que 4 millions va à riadh
ben aïssa dans ses comptes personnels
géré par roland kauffmann finalement eu
millions doit aller à slim chiboub
gendre du président tunisien ben ali et
la part du lion est pour saadi kadhafi
en deux ans seulement
de 2001 à 2003 on retrouve des paiements
pour plus de 7 millions de dollars
jacques lamarre affirme qu'il ignorait
tout de ce stratagème
vous ne saviez pas qu'ils gardaient une
partie de l'argent pour lui-même tombe
le bain il n'accepte la fuite je t'aime
a fâché d'être ça aujourd'hui elle
m'aidera porte à coups de pied avez vous
déjà vu jacques lamarre et saadi kadhafi
ensemble oui mais j'ai assisté à
plusieurs rencontres a vécu à mon avis
jacques lamarre ne pouvait pas ignorer
le lien avec ça dit même si snc lavalin
se défend d'avoir versé des pots de vin
elle déroule tout de même le tapis rouge
pour la famille kadhafi en 2005 avec
l'aide de réa benaïssa snc commandes et
une exposition des peintures de saïf
le fait est né à montréal en 2008 c'est
au tour de sadi de séjourner au canada
et de profiter des largesses de snc
lavalin
moi je dis nous faire plein de problèmes
assez vite assez canadiens peuvent
assurer sa sécurité
mag absolument pas snc se sent
l'obligation d'assumer sa sécurité
gary peeters un garde du corps est
engagée par snc lavalin il va devenir un
proche du fils kadhafi
snc lavalin paient pour le séjour de
sadi et pour que vous le protéger diop
sadi pouvait demander 5 ou 6000 $ à la
réception de l'hôtel et snc lavalin
passé derrière et remboursait on l'amène
pêcher le saumon chasser l'orignal est
celle ci lui paie des cours privés de
financer d'anglais avec un professeur de
l'université mcgill
mais ce n'est pas assez pour calmer le
jet setteur qui le fils kadhafi saadi
faisait de méchantes fait avec des
filles de la drogue tout ce que vous
voulez tout ça grâce à snc-lavalin qui
s'assuraient au final qu'il ne se
retrouvait pas dans le pétrin canada
gère particulier d'être tellement
content puis avait pas fait trop de
stupidité puis par an dont on avait une
facture de près de deux millions de
dollars messaoud abda expert en
criminalité financière voit dans ces
exemples 1,4 typique d'entreprise pris
dans un engrenage de corruption c'est
comme si vous étiez dans une cage avec
un lion puis pour qu'ils vont manger pas
vous le jetez de la viande c'est pas des
relations très saine d'andernos non on
vous aime bien vous attendent on essaye
de le garder tranquille parce qu'on
essaie de le drogué parce que on sait
qu'il part et est le projet de demain
pour payer cela benaïssa contrôler
personnellement une véritable caisse
noire
jacques lamarre nie vigoureusement que
snc lavalin et payé des pots-de-vin mais
pourtant vous saviez que l'argent est il
y avait de l'argent qui était versée à
syndiquer des films sur la main non ça
n'est pas ça non elle n'est pas acceptée
pourtant des millions transitent par
genève dans des comptes à la ffg
contrôlée par roland kauffmann sous les
ordres de riadh ben aïssa ces millions
de dollars proviennent de contrats avec
duvel approuvée par la haute direction
de snc lavalin
le stratagème utilisé au maghreb
snc lavalin le transpose chez nous à
montréal au centre universitaire de
santé de mes guil riadh ben aïssa aurait
versé un pot-de-vin à la direction de
l'hôpital pour que snc lavalin
obtiennent le contrat de construction de
ce méga chantier notre émission spéciale
snc-lavalin se poursuit tout c'est après
cette pause depuis le début des
scandales impliquant snc-lavalin une
quinzaine de personnes ont été accusées
ou criminelle de ce nombre cinq ont
plaidé coupable et ont écopé de peines
variant entre 5 ans et demi de prison et
une peine de 20 mois à purger dans la
collectivité est fait à noter les
accusations ont été retirés pour 7 des
individus dont deux qui ont invoqué les
délais déraisonnables le fameux harry
jordan il reste le procès d'un accusé et
celui contre l'entreprise elle-même
1 et luxe qui a tout changé ce qui est
au coeur des répercussions politiques en
ce moment c'est les accusations qui ont
été portées au criminel contre la
compagnie elle-même contre snc lavalin
c'est rare qu'une entreprise est accusée
snc l'a été en vertu d'une loi fédérale
qui interdit de payer des agents
étrangers ce que ça veut dire ça faisait
de payer des pots de vin à l'étranger
pour obtenir des contrats
là les accusations sont portées les
processus judiciaire est entamée il ya
une enquête préliminaire l'automne
dernier et si le juge considère que
matière à procès ça va durer des années
selon et l'enjeu aussi c'est que snc
lavalin compétitionne à l'international
avec d'autres multinationales qui on
peut tout à fait que les mêmes règles
dans leur pays
effectivement les concurrents de snc
lavalin ces entreprises là dans les pays
où elles sont basées
on passe aux états-unis en
grande-bretagne y existe depuis
plusieurs années un espèce de procédure
qui complémentaires dans le processus
judiciaire qui permet aux entreprises
qui sont accusés de corruption
d'admettre leur corps mais de pas
plaider coupable et ça ce que ça fait
c'est quai ceineray lavalin 7 va obtenir
ça c'est éviterait d'être banni de
toutes les soumissions plus contrats
publics alors on comprend pourquoi snc
lavalin souhaite en arriver à une
entente
on va écouter votre reportage justice
parallèle
snc lavalin qui est de nouveau dans
l'embarras la gendarmerie royale du
canada dépose des accusations de fraude
et de corruption contre la firme
l'entreprise est accusée d'avoir fraudé
la libye auprès de 130 millions de
dollars et d'aix aux dirigeants sont
poursuivis pour fraude dans le dossier
du centre universitaire de santé de mes
guides nous sommes non coupable à
l'envoi se battre jusqu'à la fin pour le
démontrer
mais la fin est loin le procès
concernant la fraude alléguée en libye
n'est pas prévu avant trois ans le tout
pourrait s'éterniser jusqu'en 2025
pendant ce temps la snc lavalin aurait
été en pénitence incapable de travailler
au fédéral parfois barrées à
l'international snc lavalin crie au
secours
l'aide lui vient d'ottawa sous la forme
d'une entente administrative et la lente
administratives vous permet de faire
quoi de soumissionner de continuer à
faire des contrats puis d'en gagner
encore d'autres jusqu'au bout des
poursuites jusqu'au bout des poursuites
c'était la première entente de ce genre
à être signé en retour la firme a dû
mettre en place des règlements de
conformité anticorruption il y avait une
liste noire des entreprises proscrite de
faire affaire avec l'étape
snc lavalin s'y trouvait ne pouvait pas
avoir la maîtrise d'oeuvre du pont
champlain
il y avait des concurrents étrangers qui
pressait pour avoir le contrat et le
gouvernement fait une exception à sa
propre loi pour permettre à snc 2
d'avoir le contre c'est de faire la
distinction entre ce que des individus
peuvent avoir fait est une entreprise
alors des individus qui ont fait de la
main 20 stations doivent être poursuivis
doivent payer des pénalités doivent
rembourser l'argent doivent aller en
prison si c'est le cas mais les
entreprises elles doivent continuer à
opérer pour donner des emplois
ottawa et québec parlent le même langage
on ne peu d'entreprises globales on a
senti la balle est bien sûr will go on a
bon parti préserv'eau de ce que je dis
moi simplement c'est que soyons prudents
avec nos grands fleurons les entreprises
veulent plus
elles veulent gagner au jeu de serpents
et échelles et le gros loup serait les
dpa pour des fautes pour ses clichés
negri min autrement dit des ententes à
l'amiable payer une amende éviterait
toute poursuite
basé sur le modèle américain ces
ententes représente le saint graal pour
les entreprises qui ont des ennuis
ça va te coûter 500 millions par exemple
et et en échange de ce paiement là tu
vas mettre en place dans ta compagnie
des codes d'éthique des mesures pour de
lyautey la corruption et tout va
embaucher des vérificateurs externes qui
vont en voir l'application est donc en
échange de sa la compagnie elle évite
toute poursuite criminelle
elle n'est pas trouvée coupable de rien
et elle peut continuer à soumissionner
et avoir des contrats de l'état et
d'autres organismes internationaux
[Musique]
ça mettrait fin à la poursuite compressé
pour la fraude présumée en libye je
pense que autant pour le gouvernement
que pour snc lavalin de très longs
procédure parce que des procès comme ça
c'est toujours long ce à des coûts
importants pour le gouvernement et pour
nous tandis qu'avec un dpe on peut
régler beaucoup plus rapidement un lobby
important est menée dans ce sens par
rien de moins que john manley l'ex vice
premier ministre du canada au nom du
conseil canadien des affaires
snc lavalin en est le fer de lance de
beaucoup de lobby d'affaires
on demande un changement législatif pas
seulement pour snc-lavalin mais pour les
entreprises canadiennes pour pouvoir
compétitionner à l'international avec le
même cadre réglementaire que nos grands
compétiteurs qui eux sont basés aux
états unis en grande bretagne ou en
france où là ils ont ce type de loi aux
états unis ces ententes ont rapporté 40
milliards de dollars en quinze ans ce
qui les rend populaire mais sont-elles
efficaces pour lutter contre la
corruption
pour plusieurs entreprises qui sont là
d'un syrien ça c'est rien c'est un c'est
un drop nba ce nas est une goutte dans
l'océan payer ces quelques centaines de
millions d'amande et que c'est comme une
taxe à la corruption quand on a des
actionnaires s'est toujours beaucoup
d'argent alors moi je n'appelle pas ça
une taxe à la corruption
un fragile équilibre à trouver entre
sauver nos fleurons y lutter contre la
corruption
[Musique]
après la pause la fraude qui a frappé
l'imagination tous le scandale du cuse
humain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de retour en quête avec un autre
scandale impliquant snc-lavalin le
chapitre du cuse m vous vous souviendrez
de cet épisode que particulièrement
attaché la réputation de snc lavalin ici
parce que pour une fois ce n'était pas
des scandales de corruption à l'étranger
dans des pays où on a une perception que
la corruption est un peu plus installés
mais bien ici chez nous voici un retour
sur les principaux faits de cette
enquête la plus grande faute de
corruption
l'enquêteur de marteau a expliqué la
route corps et suivie l'argent du coup
du vainqueur et vers si snc lavalin cela
met en scène pierre duhaime
l'ex pdg de la firme et riadh ben aïssa
l'ex-vice-président construction on
observe que sur un période environ un an
et demi des versements total quatre
versements totalisant 22 points 5
millions $ selon l'enquêteur pour
camoufler ce versement
les deux ex dirigeants de snc lavalin
ont créé un contrat pour un faux agent
commercial en algérie
mais l'argent a plutôt été versé dans
une société écran aux bahamas qui
appartient à un peu porteuse
l'ex-directeur du csm il ensuite
partager la somme avec son bras droit
il y en a et elbaz et son frère yoann 11
points 25 millions pour un peu porteur
11 points 25 millions pour les frères el
bass sauvé influencé comme on voit très
clairement par soit graphique les
principaux dirigeants de
du coup m en fait les gens qui avaient
le plus des gens qui avaient une
influence au niveau lot de choix durant
60 gagnants
l'enquêteur de la commission raconte
comment en échange en te porter à
utiliser un prétexte pour disqualifier
le concurrent de snc-lavalin haut à
chelles et comment il y en a une base à
donner les plans de son concurrent à
snc-lavalin qui les a copié moi j'ai un
patron qui me dit tu fais ça
[Musique]
j'étais anglais dans snc-lavalin aurait
été jusqu'à menacer son concurrent riadh
ben aïssa vice-président de sensi fait
des menaces à watten il indique que snc
va pas laisser aux échelles construire
la cuisine et que plus personne ne va
vouloir travailler avec au canada à cela
s'ajoutent des pressions politiques
l'ex président du conseil
d'administration de l'hôpital sénateur
david angus aurait appelé le premier
ministre charest pour faire avancer le
dossier
un peu plus tard dans le processus il ya
eu à ma connaissance à ce moment le plus
un contact direct
parce que là je suis plus au courant
parce que ce monsieur charest m'avait
appelé directement pour me demander
qu'est ce qu'ils devaient dire aux
sénateurs un ghost qui arrêtait pas de
le harceler durant la période des fêtes
on retient aussi que snc lavalin a
obtenu une dérogation pour ce
stationnement étagé qui est considéré en
sous sol marc perrault
malgré ça va réussir à convaincre les
urbanistes de l'arrondissement
côte-des-neiges-notre-dame-de-grâce que
le stationnement étagé est un
stationnement sous sol
cela permit à snc-lavalin est de
diminuer le coût de son projet pour
qu'il respecte le budget le groupe
concurrent n'a pas été avertie de cette
dérogation ce qui est contraire à toutes
les règles de ce ppp
la commissaire charbonneau 7 et tonique
ppp québec l'agent ce qui devait
encadrer le processus n'ait rien vu de
ces tractations
vous trouvez pas que il y avait un peu
trop de pression de la part de monsieur
pointure pour que pour vous ce n'est une
une seule une sonnette d'alarmé dit
quelque chose qui marche comme je sais
bien qu'aujourd'hui le coeur on regarde
le film par la fin on dit voyons
m'irradie moi si je trouverais des
allumés sous le nouveau en question
mais si j'avais pas d'information à
stéphane leurs huit personnes au total
sont accusés de fraude
le procès va débuter ou 2015
ce que le public a retenu de tout cet
épisode du cul zoom ccap grandes
conséquences pour les acteurs impliqués
dans la fraude
six ans de procédure se sont terminées
en queue de poisson je dirais d'abord
parce que paul que le directeur du
centre universitaire de santé de mes
guides est décédé mais surtout parce que
pas eu de procès donc toute la preuve
qu'ils étaient accumulés qu'elle est
déposée à la cour on n'y a pas eu accès
il ya quatre personnes qui ont fini par
plaider coupable à des accusations très
réduite ayons eu des sentences à la
mesure de ces accusations et l'autre
question luxe et où est passé l'argent
de cette fraude
ben effectivement que c'est bien qu'on
roule un autre problème c'est de
recouvrer les sommes qui ont été
détournés dans le cas du cul zoom ses 22
points 5 millions de dollars qui a été
payé un pot-de-vin
cet argent là est partie de montréal
s'est retrouvé aux bahamas apprécié se
sont dispersés dans des sociétés écrans
partout aux quatre coins de la planète
la justice avait réussi à à peu près
localiser où étaient ces sommes là et on
a appris récemment que des immeubles qui
ont été achetés avec une partie de cet
argent ils ont été vendus alors que
c'était complètement interdite you can
l'histoire cuisine c'est pas la seule
affaire de pots-de-vin impliquant snc
lavalin chez nous au retour de la pause
d'une autre histoire que vous avez
déterré celle de celui qu'on a surnommé
le zorro dépens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
celui qui a écopé de la plus lourde de
peine dans toutes les affaires de
corruption impliquant snc lavalin c'est
michel fournier l'ancien pdg de la
société des ponts fédéraux
michel fourni il a reçu des gros pots de
vin pour favoriser snc-lavalin dans
l'octroi de contrats de réfection du
pont jacques cartier
il a reçu plus de 2 millions de dollars
dans ses comptes en suisse
mais comme vous allez voir ce lieu pris
un certain temps avant de l'avouer
michel fournier est un libéral notoire
chef de cabinet de jean chrétien
lorsqu'il est dans l'opposition
directeur général de l'ailé québécoise
du parti libéral
jusqu'à sa nomination à la société des
ponts lorsque les conservateurs prennent
le pouvoir à ottawa
michel fournit le libéral perd son poste
en 2007 et la 55 ans il quitte la
société des ponts la politique vend sa
maison de saint jean sur richelieu et
semblent disparaître
[Musique]
nous l'avons retrouvé ici loin des ponts
et d'effroi montréalais au bout de la
route
sur cette colline en banlieue de
victoria en colombie britannique
je suis tombé sur les bons formation à
celle sortant raymond groupe vous
expliquer ce qui s'est passé pour faire
votre gestion de la société du coup
concernant un composé d aribert en
suisse notamment en conquête et pas
seulement dans votre compte est bon oui
vous avez découvert un compte à la
banque tempus contre 0 que vous avez
reçu plusieurs paiements de la société
snc lavalin dans ce conte classique
jamais comprend aucune façon malin
ces informations proviennent de l'
enquête sur iad benaïssa vous vous
souvenez cet ex vice président de snc
lavalin qui est emprisonné en suisse
depuis près de deux ans pour avoir versé
d'importants pots-de-vin à des ex
dictateur comme kadhafi en libye
surprenant alors de voir le nom de
michel fourni à paraître dans ce dossier
et recevoir des millions de dollars en
versements suspects n'ont jamais ouvert
de compte entre votre votre passeport
était donné en garantie on a vu des
photos
ce fonds mais j'ai vu les photos de
votre passeport attaché à ce compte là
qui s'appelle zorro que vous avez appelé
euros à la banque pictet
écoutez madame g bon j'ai pas eu de
compte que j'ai ouvert à des potes
pourtant les documents bancaires et
juridiques donne des détails troublants
de janvier à octobre 2002 promo tag une
agence régulièrement engagé par snc
lavalin dépose des sommes importantes
dans le conte zorro 230 mille dollars
228 1114 mille cette fois pour un total
de plus de 2 millions de dollars que se
passe-t-il à ce moment là qui pourrait
justifier ces paiements de 2000 à 2002
la société des ponts a entrepris un
grand chantier au bon jacques cartier
rappelez vous il s'agissait de refaire
tout le tablier du pont de nuit pour ne
pas perturber le trafic
un contrat de 127 millions de dollars
effectué par un consortium dirigé par
snc lavalin selon michel fournier
l'appel d'offres a été fait dans les
règles de l'art je pense que c'est parce
ailleurs mais je peux vous dire que chez
nous tout aussi été fait de façon très
claire très propre ils étaient les plus
bas soumissionnaire qu'ils avaient la
meilleure enveloppe technique
expliquez-moi pourquoi ces gens
d'arrêter sous peu à un tel point de
dire que les récents au 5e question que
nous avons posée à snc-lavalin
nous n'avons reçu qu'une phrase en
réponse nous n'avons pas d'informations
à partager relativement vos questions le
12 octobre 2000
le contrat est donné à snc-lavalin deux
semaines plus tard le 1er novembre
le couple fourni ouvre son compte en
suisse fin 2002 les travaux au pont
jacques cartier se termine
le couple ferme ce compte et transfert 2
millions de dollars dans une autre
banque pasche leurs comptes s'appelle
alors saint jean laville qui l'habite
alors prom attaques continues de leur
verser des sommes jusqu'en 2004 deux
déversements serait liée à des contrats
en libye
s'étonne les enquêteurs suisses car
michel fournier est encore à l'emploi la
société des ponts au canada j'ai jamais
reçu aucun sou de l'apport de la
personne cela valait de promo taxez nous
quelque chose l'agencé commerciale est
utilisé par snc lavalin pour tout sur le
dos il s'appelle promoteurs n'ont jamais
reçu le projet
la justice suisse pointe aux oies ont
posé des questions aux gens des synthés
laval est sur 1 4 million $ qui a été
versée à votre compte écoutez j'ai
jamais reçu de son essence et lavalin
une semaine plus tard michel fournier a
rappelé au téléphone il admet avoir bel
et bien ouvert le fameux conte euros
mais dit-il comme prête-nom pour sa
belle soeur aujourd'hui décédé qui
voulait cacher de l'argent son conjoint
pourquoi pas des soeurs recevrait des
paiements de promoteur et c'est ainsi
que promo tag aurait pu lui verser des
sommes importantes pendant des années et
tout cela selon lui
à son issue
alors anne qu'est ce qui est advenu
michel fournier ce que c'était sa belle
ça ou pas c'était pour lui évidemment il
l'a longtemps quand même essayer de
prouver que l'argent provenait du
patrimoine de sa belle soeur qui a
fabriqué une lettre appelant à l'aide
ses amis politiques mieux fini par
plaider coupable il ya eu une sentence
de cinq ans et demi de prison mais est
déjà sortie de prison alors qu'ils
lisent sans avoir fait le sixième de sa
peine
l'autre chose qui est particulière dans
cette affaire c'est que la justice a
sévi contre celui qui a reçu un
pot-de-vin
mais du côté de ceux qui auraient versés
les pots-de-vin qui auraient détourné
l'argent du côté de celle avalée il ya
personne qui a été accusé encore on va
voir ça va suivre et au retour on vous
revient avec d'autres affaires de
corruption cette fois en tunisie et en
algérie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
snc-lavalin fait des affaires au maghreb
depuis les années 70 et là aussi sur le
terrain notre équipe a déterré d'autres
affaires de pots de vin notamment en
algérie et en tunisie
début des années 2000 le prix du pétrole
explose l'état algérien lancent de
grands chantiers en dix ans snc lavalin
obtient pour 4 milliards de dollars en
contrats ici au barrage de taksebt snc
lavalin singh en 2005 un contrat de 750
millions de dollars
il s'agit de construire une station de
traitement des eaux est d'acheminer
l'eau potable dans des tuyaux
souterrains jusqu'à alger à 90 km snc
lavalin s'associe aux entreprises de
tony accurso pour réaliser ce projet
aujourd'hui le chantier est terminé
l'eau est propre il parvient la capitale
mais le contrat lui est en nous
troublent tony accurso et deux de ses
entreprises sont accusées de fraude
fiscale par le ministère du revenu du
québec
les enquêteurs ont trouvé pour 2
millions de dollars de fausses factures
attribué à ce projet
[Musique]
nous avons questionné la direction de
snc lavalin à montréal le nouveau vice
président de la division construction
qui a fait carrière à la firme revient
tout juste d'algérie il ignore où est
passé l'argent
alors s'il ya eu des choses qu'on
connaît pas qui ont été organisées par
des personnes des ex-employés avec avec
ce maillot du centre c'est pas et vous
n'avez pas pu vous apercevoir au moment
la réception des factures qu'il y avait
peut-être des choses et pensa dedans je
peux vous assurer si on savait qu'il y
avait des fausses factures ou autre on
aurait agi en conséquence bien sûr
et pourtant plusieurs personnes qui ont
travaillé à snc nous ont révélé que des
dépenses injustifiées de plus de 10
millions $ ont été faites sur ce
chantier entre autres pour l'achat de
voitures de luxe dont certaines ont été
livrés à l'extérieur de l'algérie à
radio canada nous ne sommes pas la
police mais concernant le projet de taxe
est par exemple on a pu parler à
différentes personnes j'imagine qu'à
snc-lavalin vous pouvez quand même
questionné les gens au saint des saints
cela valait pour voir qu'est ce qui
s'est passé le mot juge pas au courant
de tous ces détails que vous avez mais
s'ils ont des allégations c'est juste
les enquêtes qui vont pouvoir le couvrir
de l'argent du projet de taxe est pts se
serait retrouvé sur des comptes à genève
dans deux coquilles vides à partir d'un
certain niveau de contrat et dans le
domaine pétrolier en particulier il est
impossible d'obtenir un contrat sans
payer un pot-de-vin quelque part c c'est
devenu c'est pratiquement
institutionnalisée
cet homme dérange parce qu'ils dénoncent
la corruption en algérie
il vit à paris et son livre l'histoire
secrète du pétrole algérien est interdit
en algérie
c'est un ancien dirigeant de sonatrach
la société nationale des hydrocarbures
il explique comment les contrats sont
obtenus grâce à des ententes secrètes
avec des ministres et surtout avec des
généraux de l'armée comme l'impression
que la terreur de la valeur c'est une
coutume qui existe depuis longtemps
oui parce que dès que l'aval est arrivé
en algérie d amour du premier contrat
j'ai eu des progrès qui ont été payés ce
premier contrat de laval est en algérie
remonte à 1981
c'est ce monument symbole de
l'indépendance du pays
une prouesse technique réalisée par une
équipe de québécois tels que le rappelle
ce vidéos corporatifs de la firme
quelques heures avant son inauguration
l'imposant bâtiment est terminée
jacinthe et un défi incroyable des gens
travaillaient plus haut depuis tempête
pas tempête
[Musique]
le monument sur les hauteurs d'alger
attire encore aujourd'hui les badauds
malti a été impliqué dans ce chantier
il se rappelle que ses supérieurs
avaient tenté de lui forcer la main pour
accorder un contrat à laval est un
contrat pour lequel la firme n'était pas
qualifié selon lui je suis vite de
l'impression bon j'ai dit non tu
comprendras prêté par ce avec l'aval en
en phase avec la plus il y avait des
commissions au bout un parce que sinon
pourquoi quelqu'un qui ne connaît pas le
secteur qu'il connaît pas le métier bien
se mêler et vous dire prenez telle
entreprise mais pour des raisons comme
celle-là lavalin était alors dirigée par
bernard lamarre l'aîné de la famille
aujourd'hui retraité est malade il nous
a accordé une entrevue au téléphone il
nie avoir donné des poudres est on
apprend virtuel de problème donc pouvoir
compter sur une fusion donnait pourtant
cet ancien colonel du drs l'équivalent
algérien de la cia nous affirme le
contraire il soutient que le drs avait
fait enquête et obtenu des preuves de
cette corruption
j'ai connu ça fait connu non c'est pas
qu'on eut renoncé
l'enquète avait été à l'époque entamée
par les services de renseignements
algériens qui avaient
et puis qui était parvenu à des pistes
probant de matériel et à ce moment là
snc lavalin si vous continuez nous
allons donner la liste des bénéficiaires
des commissions et il ya eu des
instructions à l'époque pour dire stop
et l'umq est ils ont fait arrêter langue
est dans son nouveau politique donc
l'enquète a été arrêté le jour où 10 des
instructions avaient été données pour
que les enquêtes soient stoppés elle a
été stoppée
d'autres lucratifs contrats suivent
centrale électrique au gaz
1.3 milliards de dollars 1.2 milliard
pour une autre usine de traitement du
gaz en plein milieu du désert
les affaires vont bien trop bien pour
être dans les règles
selon cet employé toujours chez snc
lavalin et qui bien au fait de ce qui se
passait en afrique du nord
snc lavalin était très choyé pour le
nombre de contrats qu'ils obtenaient en
algérie il dépassait toute normalité en
termes de contrats obtenus par rapport à
ceux soumissionner exemple un très bon
estimateur va gagner à peu près 10% des
contrats et en algérie on obtenait plus
de 90% des contrats auxquels vous
soulignez auxquels nous sommes ici
oignons est ce un taux de succès de 90%
c'est sa part anormale
c'est effectivement normal
à tunis la capitale de la tunisie où le
printemps arabe a commencé
riadh ben aïssa possède une luxueuse
villa tout juste derrière le palais
présidentiel
une autre était en construction pour les
tunisiens comme les libyens c'est
l'heure des comptes
samir et m'a dit est médecin le jour le
soir ils traquent les corrompus depuis
qu'il a vu les millions au palais du
président et ses jurés de retrouver
l'argent versé en pots de vin dans son
pays entre autres par snc-lavalin
je peux vous garantir que les 11
millions de tunisiens étaient sous le
choc
durable
de voir toute une banque
chez le président
[Musique]
dans sa ville à sousse ou snc lavalin a
grandi une centrale thermique
sami remadi a participé à l' enquête qui
a trouvé des preuves d'actes de
corruption au plus haut échelon de snc
lavalin vous désirez que snc lavalin
soient sanctionnés absolument
et on arrêtera pas
jusqu'à ce qu'elle est c'est à dire ce
qu'elles soient sanctionnées pas
seulement est celle ci la marque et tous
ceux qui ont fait des appareils en libye
comme en tunisie les premières victimes
les citoyens aimeraient recouvrir les
millions de dollars détournés
le problème de la récupération de
l'argent c'est pas seulement un problème
d'argent c'est un problème de dignité
qu'on doit récupérer
le cas la suite de ce reportage vous
avez trouvé d'autres confirmations des
pots de vin oui après quelques années on
a eu accès au paname en paix pesé dans
cette chute de documents là on a trouvé
les contrats qui était utilisé par
snc-lavalin pour dissimuler le paiement
des pots de vin sur certains projets en
algérie
mais malgré ces une nouvelle preuve là
il n'y a pas eu de conséquences
judiciaires pour snc-lavalin ni au
canada ni en ag faut quand même dire que
la compagnie traîne un genre de bouhlel
pour ce contrat l'international
à cause de ce qui s'est passé au
bangladesh là-bas la banque mondiale a
enquêté sur des allégations de
corruption concernant snc lavalin qui
étaient prêts à payer un pot de vin et
la banque mondiale a décidé de bannir la
firme sur tous les contrats qu'elle
finance à travers le monde et ça pour 10
ans et ça aurait pu avoir de grandes
conséquences pour un contrat chez nous
oui celui du pont champlain si snc
lavalin le construit à l'heure actuelle
et c'est grâce à une entente
administrative avec le canada qui lui
permet de faire des travaux malgré les
procédures juridiques parce que
normalement les entreprises condamnées
peuvent pas obtenir des contrats et sur
le terrain au maghreb qu'est ce qu'on
vous disait c'est quoi la perception des
gens sur snc lavalin les gens espéraient
que le canada puisse faire la lumière
sur les pots de vin qui était payée dans
leur pays parce qu'ils font des très peu
d'espoir en sur la justice de leur
propre pays malheureusement et ce qui
n'est pas arrivé toujours pas
d'accusation pour ces épisodes là au
maghreb année luxe était très éclairant
de revenir sur toutes vos révélations
des dernières années surtout dans le
contexte où snc lavalin continue à faire
couler beaucoup d'encre ces jours ci au
nom de toute l'équipe
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là est revenu
nous laisse une prochaine pour une autre
enquête
[Musique]